scattiamo fuori alla luce così non ci
potrà raggiungere almeno
che paghi io possa rimanere qui alla
luce del sole lei non potrà arrivare qui
guardate
com'è tanto team order o prima o poi di
certo non solo fuori alla luce il
proprio mandato viltà nei giovani
eccola qui tanto prima o poi lo prenderò
non morde rho
[Musica]
non sono sicuro che
sicuramente molto arrabbiata ho cercato
di nascondersi non lo usa guardate che
bella questa farfalla
davis così dare un piano ora attirare
vitale quale morter lo c'è solo un modo
per attirare vitale basta semplicemente
del cibo e lui ci cascherà come ci
cascano
ecco fatto a tirare o vitale con due
pezzi di focaccia ora devo solo decidere
dove sistemare questa trappola
sarà proprio una trappola perfetta
[Musica]
lascerò le vocazioni
io mi nasconderò qua sopra così potrò
godermi la scena
dietro
alla porta finale sta già arrivando
[Musica]
o no il cannes e berlino
ha visto il pane la focaccia
pure mangiarlo lui adesso
ok così mangerà la trappola barbie tale
non posso trasformare un cane in vampiro
almeno credo per fortuna non lo sta
mangiando
sembra che abbia capito
[Musica]
se mangiare o no il pane
sento
pareggio sul tavolo
mondo sta mangiando la mia trappola ha
rubato un pezzo di pane
[Musica]
così vitale non arriverà mai
come farò ad attirare vitale
agendo tutto
[Musica]
eccolo forse siamo ancora in tempo per
farlo cascare nella trappola
cosa stai facendo un vino veniva tutto
questo odore di focaccia è rimangiato
tutto tu non ci credo mi ha rubato la
focaccia il cane ha macchiato dotta
trappola va bene allora non c'è più
niente da mangiare per me ne vado
devo inventarmi qualcos'altro
ho un'idea
metterò del cibo che il cane non mangerà
almeno credo
e cioè mettere una banana questa
sicuramente non la mangio rare il cane è
vero però siccome vitale mangiatutto
arriverà comunque cadrà nella mia
trappola il cane rimasto lì a
sorvegliare il tavolo come faccio devo
scegliere un altro nascondiglio
posso mettere la parola sul tavolo
perché c'è
questo cane che sorveglia tutto dove
potrei metterla faccio la banana qua
e io mi nasconderò li
sento ancora odore di cibo
ma non mi sembra del cibo buono come
quelle focaccia
una brava
sa chi avrà lasciato una banana acque
merlino circe
non so
[Musica]
purtroppo ora di chiudere
subito
ti conviene aprire perché ho qua e di
cannes e
berlino
tempo
cinque minuti
se non rientro cinque minuti il giocane
verrà trasformata
cinque minuti o tempo sono cinque minuti
per trovare una soluzione
devo salvare marino ma anche anita
spieghiamoci
forse posso trovare una soluzione qui
nella libreria verità vita un vampiro
vero forse posso trovare un libro sui
bambini ma niente piatto era qualcosa
vediamo
dove sarà
[Musica]
akula tra cui air è un vampiro
devo trovare una soluzione equa in
queste pagine ma devo leggerlo in
pochissimo tempo
farò
[Musica]
basta sono impaziente per evitare anche
perché se non
nullo o patate
in questo poco tempo ho letto nel libro
che per sconfiggere un vampiro bisogno
colpirlo con un paletto di legno al
cuore e io non posso fare questo ad
anita devo trovare un'altra soluzione ho
anche letto in questo libro che il punto
debole dei vampiri all'aglio ecco perché
non è piaciuta la mia buonissima pasta
aglio olio e peperoncino che lo ha fatto
prima
vita breve
il mio servo fedele
da
anni da vampiro
si è nascosta
unità
non so perché ma credo che abita le
abbia qualcosa in mente questa volta è
lui che vuole fare un canteremo una
trappola
quindi non mi fido finché non capisco
che cosa dietro alla schiena non sia
fuori dal mio nascondiglio o qualcosa
qui in partenza è
qualcosa che ti possa placare la sete
dove sei
strano conosco un sistema per farla
uscire fuori subito
il corso full
so io come farla uscire allo scoperto
immediatamente
vediamo se salta fuori questa volta
un po di lupi se
va bene stava a chi oggi fra cui la 30 a
destra e cosa vedi nascondevi dai tu ti
stai già indebolendo o qualcosa qui per
aiutarti gli invitati
alcol
credimi ti sentirai meglio dopo anzi
tornerà in te stessa pieni
ma una volta che
sarò lì km la card con un sopravvivere
ecco
allora che cosa devi darmi brigati prima
vittima or da
un bel pò che danno
[Musica]
o no
forniamo ti senti bene
per niente taglio sanità io volevo solo
farti tornare in te stessa con quest
anno ho letto un libro dei vampiri che
il vostro punto debole e l'aglio quindi
ho pensato che forse colpendo di colombo
che ad aglio avrebbe funzionato
uso
[Musica]
che succede qui tale unità che cosa è
successo
perché mi metto a questo vestito è una
lunga storia
andiamo te lo spiego davanti a una tazza
di tè caldo e dei biscotti
[Risate]
[Musica]